♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" FINALLY
HAPPY STORY FROM ONES.
OUTBURSTS OF IRREPRESSIBLE JOY
ERUPTED THROUGHOUT THE EXCLUSIVE
ISLAND COMMUNITY OF MARTHA'S
VINEYARD MASSACHUSETTS LAST
NIGHT.
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS MARTHA'S
VINEYARD HAS HAD THE SOUL
CRUSHING EFFECTS OF HIS OWN
WHITENESS.
NOW RESIDENTS UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE WAS ON THE ONE CURE, THEY
BADLY NEEDED DIVERSITY.
THEY OFTEN SAID SO.
DESPITE THEIR VERY BEST EFFORTS
OVER MANY YEARS DIVERSITY NEVER
CAME.
IT WAS TRAGIC.
IMAGINE AN 18TH CENTURY BRITISH
ADRIFT ON THE HIGH SEAS WITH NO
LINES.
SAILORS SLOWLY GOING MAD
CONVULSING, DYING EXCRUCIATING
DEATHS FROM SCURVY.
EXCEPT IT WASN'T LIME JUICE THEY
LACKED A PLENTY OF THAT BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T MAKE A GIN AND TONIC
WITHOUT IT.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD LACKED WAS
DIVERSITY WHICH IS THIS A
STRENGTH.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD WAS A VERY
WEAK PLACE, AS OF YESTERDAY
MORNING ISLAND WITH 89% WHITE.
MONOCHROMATIC AND --
EVERYONE WAS A RICH DEMOCRAT.
80% FOOT OF HER JOE BIDEN.
THE MEDIAN HOME PRICE WAS OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEN IN A SINGLE BLESSING
MOMENT EVERYTHING CHANGED.
RELIEF ARRIVED FROM AN UNLIKELY
SOURCE.
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS OF
FLORIDA DECIDED TO HELP OTHER
STATES DESPERATELY IN NEED SO
YESTERDAY HE SENT 50 ILLEGAL
ALIENS, MOST OF THEM FROM
VENEZUELA TO THE MARTHA'S
VINEYARD AIRPORT.
THEY TRAVELED FROM SAN ANTONIO
AND FILING INTO THEIR NEW HOME
ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
CBS BOSTON REPORTS AFTER LANDING
THE GROUP WANDERED ABOUT THREE
AND A HALF MILES THE AIRPORT
INTO TOWN.
THEREBY INSTANTLY IMPROVING IT.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE UNDER STRAIN
JUBILATION ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD
TONIGHT LONG-SUFFERING ISLANDERS
FINALLY RESCUED FROM THEIR OWN
OPPRESSIVE WHITENESS.
IN FACT IT'S COLDER NOW TO CHECK
IN ON THIS LIBERATIONS.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: LESS UNEXPECTED,
OUR PRODUCERS ARE TELLING US
THAT THEY ARE NO TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS THAT IS A LIVE SHOT
FROM MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND
MASSACHUSETTS RIGHT NOW.
WHERE WERE THE WEEPING JOYFUL
CROWDS?
WHERE WAS THE CHAMPAGNE AND THE
TICKER TAPE?
WE EXPECTED TIMES SQUARE ON V-J
DAY.
WHAT WE GOT WAS A CEMETERY AT
MIDNIGHT.
WHAT?
MAYBE IT'S NOT SO CONFUSING.
WE THINGS AREN'T AS THEY SEEM.
OUR FIRST CLUE IS BARACK OBAMA.
BARACK OBAMA IS A PART-TIME
RESIDENT OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD,
AS YOU KNOW THE COUNTRY'S
GREATEST OF DIVERSITY.
FOR YEARS OBAMA TOLD US THAT
IMMIGRANTS WERE BETTER THAN
AMERICANS.
THERE WERE HOLIER, THEY MAKE OUR
COUNTRY STRONG.
>> AMERICA HAS BEEN AND ALWAYS
BEEN A NATION OF IMMIGRANTS.
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY,
IMMIGRANTS HAS COME TO OUR
SHORES WAVE AFTER WAVE.
FROM EVERY CORNER OF THE GLOBE.
EVERYONE OF US, UNLESS WERE
NATIVE AMERICAN HAS AN ANCESTOR
WHO WAS BORN SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES AMERICA
SPECIAL.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES US STRONG.
THE BASIC IDEA OF WELCOMING
IMMIGRANTS TO OUR SHORES
ESSENTIAL TO OUR WAY OF LIFE.
IT IS IN OUR DNA.
>> Tucker: I WAS BASICALLY THE
WHOLE PRESIDENCY RIGHT THERE FOR
EIGHT YEARS.
OBAMA LECTURING US ABOUT
DIVERSITY, BUT HE DIDN'T JUST
TALK ABOUT IT HE SPENT HIS TWO
YEARS IN OFFICE MAKING CERTAIN
THAT PLACES LIKE DES MOINES,
IOWA, AND PORTLAND, MAINE,
BECAME MUCH LESS WHITE THAN THE
PREVIOUS HAD BEEN.
BECAUSE AS HE SO OFTEN TOLD US
WHITENESS IS BAD IT'S A DISEASE.
SO WE WERE CALLED BEING A LITTLE
BIT INFUSED WE SAW THAT
BARACK OBAMA SPENT $12 MILLION
TO FIND A BATHROOM OCEANFRONT
PROPERTY ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD
WHICH IS ONE OF THE WIDEST
PLACES ON EARTH.
REALLY?
MARTHA'S VINEYARD?
WHY NOT BALTIMORE?
OR GARY, INDIANA?
IT'S A REALLY NO MORE
REAL ESTATE IN DETROIT FOR THE
OBAMA FAMILY?
AND THEN IN 2019 MICHELLE OBAMA
EXPLAINED IT TO US LISTEN TO
THIS.
>> WE GREW UP IN.
CALLED WHITE FLIGHT.
THAT FAMILIES LIKE OURS
UPSTANDING FAMILIES LIKE OURS WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO THEM BETTER.
AS WE MOVED IN WHITE FOLKS MOVED
OUT.
BECAUSE THEY WERE AFRAID OF
WATER FAMILIES REPRESENTED.
I WE STOPPED THERE WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THIS OUT OF THE WORLD
BECAUSE I WANT TO REMIND WHITE
FOLKS WE ALL WERE RUNNING FROM
US AND YOU ARE STILL RUNNING.
[LAUGHS]
BECAUSE WE ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN
THE IMMIGRANT FAMILIES THAT ARE
MOVING IN, THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
COMING FROM OTHER PLACES TO TRY
AND DO BETTER.
[APPLAUSE]
SO I FEEL A SENSE OF INJUSTICE.
>> Tucker: THERE SHE WAS HER
MINING WHITE FOLKS WHO NEED
REMINDING THAT THE OBAMA'S ARE
NO DIFFERENT FROM THE IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES MOVING IN.
THEY ARE STILL RUNNING A SHE
JUST SAID.
ASCETICS POINTED TO US.
THE OBAMA'S WERE IN FACT
DISGUISED IMMIGRANTS.
SO WHEN THEY MOVED TO A SEASIDE
COMPOUND IS NOT SUPPOSED TO LIVE
IN LUXURY, NO, OBVIOUSLY THE
POINT IS TO DIVERSIFY MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
TO STRIKE A BLOW FOR JUSTICE.
I MADE SENSE TO US WE FEEL
BETTER.
BUT THEN LAST NIGHT HAPPENED AND
WE START TO REAR THINK OUR
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE OBAMA'S,
ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS.
BECAUSE A PLANE LOAD OF HIGHLY
DIVERSE IMMIGRANTS ARRIVED ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD TO JOIN THE
OBAMA'S, BUT THE OBAMA STUDENT
WELCOME THEM.
IT WAS ON A WORD FROM BRUCKEL OR
MICHELLE OBAMA.
BARACK WASN'T WAITING AT THEM TO
GIVE THEM FLOWERS.
HE DIDN'T INVITE A SINGLE
VENEZUELAN TO HIS HOME.
HOW COME?
COULD IT BE THAT BARACK OBAMA
ISN'T REALLY, ACTUALLY IN REAL
LIFE IN FAVOR OF DIVERSITY AT
ALL?
COULD BECAUSE MARK WE CAN'T SAY,
BUT WE CAN TELL YOU ONE WHAT
PEOPLE REALLY THINK GO AHEAD AND
IGNORE WHAT THE SAY AND WATCH
HOW THEY LIVE.
BY THAT MEASURE THE ONE THAT
MATTERS IS BARACK OBAMA AND
MICHELLE OBAMA ARE EVERY BIT AS
BIGOTED AS ANY BOARD MEMBER OR
ANY RESTRICTED COUNTRY CLUB IN
THE DEEP SOUTH.
ASSUMING THAT THOSE STILL EXIST.
THOSE PEOPLE?
THEY'RE NOT DATING MY DAUGHTER I
CAN TELL YOU THAT.
WE LEARNED THIS WEEK THAT
BARACK OBAMA REALLY IS A RACIST
AND NOT IN THE WAY YOU ALWAYS
ASSUME.
HE CERTAINLY SEEMS TO COME UP
BUT HE ALSO DEMANDS TO LIVE
AROUND THEM.
ONLY THEM.
THE OBAMA'S TO BE FAIR ARE NOT
ALONE.
THE FRIENDS OF THE NEWS NETWORKS
FEEL EXACTLY THE SAME WAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE EXACTLY THE
SAME SORT OF PEOPLE.
CNN SPENT THE DAY INTERVIEWING
PEOPLE CONNECTED TO SOME PART OF
MARTHA'S VINEYARD TURNS OUT THAT
PRECISELY NONE OF THEM WERE
EXCITED ABOUT THE PLANE LOAD OF
VENEZUELANS.
ONE OF THEM STATE REP FOR THE
ISLAND EVEN BLAMED THIS SHOW FOR
THE SUDDEN BLESSED SEARCH AND
DIVERSITY.
WATCH THIS.
>> RON DeSANTIS RON DeSANTIS
AND REPUBLICANS MIGHT WANT TO
PLAY POLITICAL GAMES OF PEOPLE'S
LIVES, I BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
INCREDIBLY INHUMANE TO BE USING
WOMEN, CHILDREN, AND FAMILIES AS
A POLITICAL PAWN.
TO BE TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION.
>> Tucker: WOW SEE IF YOU CAN
FOLLOW THIS YEAR 1 PENNY IS LESS
ILLEGAL ALIENS SHOW UP IN
BROWNSVILLE, TEXAS, ONE OF THE
POOREST CITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES THEY ARE NOBLE
STRIVERS, THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A
BETTER LIFE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
WE APPLAUD THEM, GOOD LUCK IN
BROWNSVILLE.
WHEN THESE VERY SAME PEOPLE
JUMPED THE MOAT GET A FREE
FLIGHT TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND
SOMETHING ELSE ENTIRELY.
IT IS AS A STATE TO STATE REP
INCENTIVE SAYS IT'S GAME WITH
POLITICAL'S LIVES.
THESE IMMIGRANTS CAN WANDER INTO
A CLAMBAKE BY ACCIDENT, OR WORSE
MUCH WORSE.
EARLIER TODAY CNN ANCHOR TO WHO
JUST GOT FIRED BY THE WAY THIS
MORNING, THIS MORNING.
HE INTERVIEWED A FILMMAKER KEN
BURNS.
HE IS FAMOUS, BUT SAID EXACTLY
THE MIDDLE AGE PRESTIGE WHO
SPENDS AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME
OWNING AROUND MARTHA'S VINEYARD
LOOKING FOR THE FAMOUS PEOPLE.
HE IS IN A FILM OUT THAT BLAMES
UNITED STATES OF ALL COUNTRIES
ON EARTH FOR THE HOLOCAUST.
NOW THAT THE WORLD WAR II
GENERATION IS PASSED KEN BURNS
CAN DO THAT.
THERE'S NO CHANCE AT ANGRY
VETERANS WILL SHOP AT HIS HOUSE
AND BEAT HIM WITH THEIR CANES
FOR BESMIRCHING THE MEMORY OF
THEIR CLOSEST FRIENDS WHO DIED
IN HER EARLY 20s THE.
SO HE CAN SAY WHATEVER HE WANTS
AND HE BELIEVES THEM.
SO THIS MORNING HE PLAYED THE
ROLE OF THE HOLOCAUST EXPERT.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE DISCOVERED?
HE HAS DISCOVERED THAT
RON DeSANTIS SENDING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IS PRETTY MUCH THE
SAME WAY WHAT HITLER DID.
A PRETTY MUCH EXACTLY.
WATCH THIS.
>> ALL OF YOUR DOCUMENTARIES ARE
ABOUT HISTORY.
ALL OF THEM ALSO MAKE YOU THINK
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE NOW, AND WE
WOKE UP TO THE NEWS THIS MORNING
AT GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS OF
FLORIDA SENT TO PLANE LOADS OF
MIGRANTS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
OFF THE COAST OF MASSACHUSETTS.
>> THIS NOT A 1-1 THIS IS NOT A
PARALLEL HERE ANYWAY.
IT DOES ADDRESS SOME OF THE SAME
THEMES.
>> THIS IS COMING STRAIGHT OUT
OF THE AUTHORITARIAN PLAYBOOK.
THIS IS WHAT IS SO DISTURBING
ABOUT THE SANCHEZ IT TO USE
HUMAN BEINGS TO WEAPONIZE
HUMAN BEINGS FOR A POLITICAL
PURPOSE.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN?
IS LITERARY, LITERALLY JUST LIKE
THE HOLOCAUST.
THE HORRORS IT, IS.
AND IT MAY BE, BUT EVERYTHING IS
RELATIVE.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD MIGHT BE A
MODERN-DAY DEATH CAMP, BUT
COMPARED TO WHAT LEGAL IT ALIENS
USUALLY GO IT'S NOT THAT BAD.
LET'S COMPARE THIS.
ON YOUR SCREEN YOU'LL SEE IMAGES
RECENTLY SHOT FROM AMERICA'S
BORDER TOWNS WHICH ARE NOW
COMPLETELY OVERRUN UNDER
JOE BIDEN'S IMMIGRATION POLICY.
YOU NOTICE IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY
CHAOS, VIOLENCE, AND SUE'S.
NOW WE WILL TAKE YOU TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, IT IS PERHAPS, BUT IN
A VERY HIGH DIFFERENT WAY.
FAMILIES ARE EATING TOGETHER ON
BALCONIES OVERLOOKING THE WATER,
WOMEN DOING THEIR SHOPPING AND A
QUAINT LITTLE TOWN ON BICYCLES.
COUPLES STROLLING ALONG THE
BOARDWALK.
SAILBOATS, IT DOESN'T LOOK THAT
BAD.
OH BUT THAT IS EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM THAT THE MEDIA TOLD US
TODAY.
IT MARTHA'S VINEYARD MIGHT SEEM
LIKE ONE OF THE RICHEST PLACE ON
THE PLANET, BUT SOMEHOW,
SOMEHOW, THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
SOCIAL SERVICES THERE.
UNLIKE BROWNSVILLE.
CBS NEWS PUT IT THAT MARTHA'S
VINEYARD IS NOT AN URBAN
METROPOLITAN AREA WITH A ROBUST
SOCIAL SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE IS NO JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OR IMMIGRATION WORK MIGRANTS CAN
DO THE SILENT HEARINGS.
THE SNOW ICE FIELD OFFICE WHERE
MIGRANTS CAN CHECK IT.
NOW, BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS AN URBAN
AREA WITH A ROBUST SOCIAL
SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE TO OTHER
PEOPLE GET THE DEAL WITH.
AND HONESTLY THAT IS TRUE, IT
IS, THE WHOLE IDEA.
THAT IS WHY HE SENT THE ILLEGAL
ALIENS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
A PEOPLE WHO MAKE AN ADVOCATE
FOR CERTAIN POLICIES SHOULD AT
SOME POINT HAVE TO LIVE WITH
THOSE POLICIES.
UNTIL NOW THEY HAVEN'T HAD TO.
BILL GATES WAS MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, SO WAS OPRAH, JAMES
TAYLOR, SPIKE LEE, AMY SCHUMER,
AND MANY MORE.
ALL OF THEM EVERYONE IS A MUCH
BETTER PERSON THAN YOU ARE
BECAUSE THEY SUPPORT DIVERSITY.
AND NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME THERE
AND HAVE SOME DIVERSITY.
IT'S JUST A BEGINNING, MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WILL BE MANY, MANY MORE
ILLEGAL ALIENS, TENS OF
THOUSANDS WORK TO THE ISLAND IS
NO LONGER MAJORITY WHITE.
ONLY THEN CAN IT BE A GOOD
PLACE.
AT THE SAME TIME THE PEOPLE WHO
CURRENTLY GO TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD ORGANA HAVE TO KEEP
GOING THERE.
THEY CAN'T RUN AWAY TO SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
THAT WOULD BE IMMORAL.
IT WOULD BE AS MICHELLE OBAMA
HAS TOLD US, WHITE FLIGHT.
NOW MASSIVE DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES
WERE ALSO MAKE A DIFFERENT SORT
OF PLACE.
THAT IS OKAY.
CHANGE IS GOOD.
ANYONE WHO FEARS CHANGE IS A
RACIST.
WE KNOW THAT FOR SURE BECAUSE
THEY'VE TOLD US THAT FOR YEARS.
SWEAR YOU MIGHT ASK WHAT ALL OF
THESE NEW PEOPLE LIVE ON SUCH A
SMALL ISLAND?
SIMPLE.
FIRST THEY CAN OCCUPY
BARACK OBAMA'S COMPOUND, THERE'S
NO REASON OBAMA NEEDS THEM AT
SPACE.
NOBODY NEEDS OF SPACE.
YOU COULD PROBABLY FIT A DOZEN
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES IN
BARACK OBAMA'S POOL HOUSE AND
ANOTHER FIVE OR SIX IN THE
PANTRY.
LET'S KEEP GOING.
BUILD A SOCCER FIELD ON THE LAWN
AND OUTDOOR GOLD BARBECUE BY THE
BACK LAWN AND BINGO, YOU HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT WILL BE ENOUGH.
THE VINEYARD IS GONNA NEED
SHANTYTOWNS FOR ALL THESE NEW
PEOPLE BUT WE CAN'T CALL THEM
SHANTYTOWNS HONESTLY THAT IS
DEMEANING.
SO WERE GONNA CALL THEM
TOWNSHIPS AFTER OBAMA'S FAVORITE
COUNTRY AND AM READY GIVE THEM
DIGNIFIED NAMES TO SUGGEST SOME
KIND OF VICTORY OVER ADVERSITY.
MANDELA, CESAR CHAVEZ BILL.
INSIDE EACH ONE WILL PUT A
PLAQUE WITH THAT FAMOUS POEM
JUST SO EVERYONE KNOWS THAT
THESE ARE NOT ORDINARY FAVELAS
THESE ARE MORE VICTORIES.
AS A SIGN SAY AND MARTHA'S
VINEYARD TO THIS DAY, NO HUMAN
IS ILLEGAL, LOVE IS LOVE.
THAT'S JUST SCIENCE.
SPEAKING OF SCIENCE, WHAT WILL
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF ALL
THE SIOUX DEPONENT BE A QUESTION
MARK THAT IS A MASSIVE CONCERN
FOR MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
IT'S NOT A CONCERN.
NONE OF THESE NEW TOWNSHIPS WILL
HAVE RUNNING WATER OR
ELECTRICITY.
SO BY DEFINITION, THEY WILL BE
CARBON NEUTRAL.
IT'LL BE PARTLY GROWING
EVOLUTION.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT SERVICES
WILL BE STRAIGHT EITHER BECAUSE
HE WILL BE NEEDED.
NONE OF THESE NEW ARRIVALS ARE
BOUND BY LOCAL LAWS.
WHY WOULD THEY BE?
THEY IGNORED FEDERAL LAW TO GET
HERE COMES AS NO REASON THAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE TO OBSERVE THE
VINEYARDS ORDINANCES AGAINST
DRUNK DRIVING.
IN CASE THERE ARE STILL VINEYARD
HER'S WHO HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PROTECT WHAT THEY OWN, THINK
AGAIN PEOPLE.
WE REFERRED YOU TO THE CASE OF
THE FASCISTS MCCLOSKEY FAMILY IN
ST. LOUIS WHO ONCE TRIED THAT,
TRIED TO DEFEND AND THEY GOT
INDICTED FOR IT SO THAT'S NOT
ALLOWED.
WE CAN'T FULLY TRUST YOU,
SOMEONE IS AND HOW TO GO
DOOR-TO-DOOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOT ONE PERSON MARTHA'S VINEYARD
KEEPS A GUN AT HOME.
BECAUSE SELF-DEFENSE CAN BE
TEMPTING, EVEN FOR DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS.
THERE'S A LOT OF CHANGE FOR THE
VINEYARD AND THEY ARE GOING TO
START WORK SOON THE SUMMER
SEASON BEGINS ON MEMORIAL DAY.
SO WHEN AMY SCHUMER SHOWS UP TO
HER PLACE IN JUNE, SHE BETTER BE
READY TO FIND A LEGAL ALIEN
FAMILY USING HER BATH TOLLS AND
HOPE THAT SHE DOESN'T COMPLAIN
ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE AS JOE BIDEN OFTEN
REMINDS US ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
IS A GIFT.
>> President Biden: THE REASON
WHY A LEGAL AS WELL AS
UNDOCUMENTED.
THE REASON WHY OUR SOCIETY IS
FUNCTIONING.
THE REASON WHY OUR ECONOMY IS
GROWING.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT.
WE STAND UP AND WE ACT LIKE IT'S
A BURDEN.
IT IS NOT A BURDEN.
IT IS A GIFT.
"THE FIVE" HEAR THAT?
YOU HEAR THAT?
IT'S NOT A BURDEN IT'S A GIFT
DUMBO.
>> Tucker: MARTHA'S VINEYARD
RECEIVED AN ENORMOUS GIFT LAST
TIME THINK ABOUT A PERPETUAL
CHRISTMAS BUT NOISIER.
AND YOU CAN'T BEAT THE TIMING IS
JOHN PIERRE JUST REMINDED US
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE ITS
HISPANIC HERITAGE MONTH,
PERFECT.
SO ROLL WITH IT MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
THINGS ARE ABOUT TO CHANGE A LOT
FOR YOU.
BUT THAT'S OKAY, RADICAL
DESTRUCTIVE CHANGE IS THE
ESSENCE OF ANTIRACISM.
AND AS HE TOLD US SO MANY TIMES
YOU SUPPORT ANTIRACISM.
THE LESS WE NEED TO REMIND YOU,
AND IN ANY CASE PRETTY SOON
YOU'LL HAVE NO MEMORY OF THE WAY
THINGS WERE BEFORE.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD WILL FEEL AND
LOOK JUST LIKE EL PASO AT ALL
SEEM NORMAL TO YOU.
WHAT IS EL PASO LIKE YOU WONDER?
HAVE A BEEN THERE LATELY?
OKAY, HERE ARE SOME RECENT
PICTURES.
>> I WANT TO SEE YOU AN EXACT
LOOK OF OVERSEEING OUT HERE.
WERE RIGHT NEXT TO THE GREYHOUND
BUS STATION WHERE I WAS YOU'VE
BEEN TELLING YOU FOR DAYS NOW
MIGRANTS, MOSTLY A LARGE GROUP
OF VENEZUELANS.
IT HAS BEEN USING THIS AREA AS A
TEMPORARY CAMP AND A HOME.
WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO
FROM EARLIER THIS MORNING AND
OVERNIGHT WHERE YOU CAN SEE HAVE
STOPPED SLEEPING ARRANGEMENTS ON
CARDBOARD AND MATTRESSES IN THE
SAME SPOT HERE OUTSIDE THE BUS
STATION.
ANOTHER CITY LEADER SAYS THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS TO AVOID
PEOPLE ON THE STREETS, SINCE
THEY HAVE BEEN SO OVERWHELMED
WITH THE LARGE NUMBERS COMING
IN, THEY HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
RELEASE AS SUCH.
AS MORE AND MORE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ON THE STREETS IN RECENT
DAYS, SANITATION AND CLEANLINESS
HAVE BECOME A CONCERN OUT HERE.
NOT SEEING ANY PORTA-POTTIES OR
SHOWERS OR SINKS AND AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE SMELL IS BEGINNING
TO ADD UP.
>> Tucker: A WOW.
LOOK, EL PASO IS VENEZUELANS
TOO.
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S BRIMMING
WITH DIVERSITY AND THE GIFT OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THAT'LL BE A GREAT TOWN
MASSACHUSETTS SOON.
BUT WE CAN'T STOP THERE WHY
WOULD BE?
IF ARE REALLY GONNA MAKE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD LOOK LIKE THE
WORLD THE PEOPLE ON A VACATION
HAVE CREATED FOR THE REST OF US?
WE ARE GETTING TO IMPORT
GRAFFITI ARTISTS COME ARMED
ROBBERS AND SUBWAY --
MANY, MANY OF THOSE.
AND THEIR TENTS.
WHY SHOULD TO BE LIVING OUTSIDE
YOUR HOUSE WHEN THEY COULD BE
CAMPED ON BARACK OBAMA'S 12 ME A
DOLLAR LAWN.
THAT SEEMS PRETTY FAIR WHY ISN'T
IT FAIR?
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T EXPECT OBAMA
TO SEE AT THE SAME WAY, HE IS A
RACIST AS WE ESTABLISHED AND SO
APPARENTLY ARE HIS FEDERAL LOW
LIBERALS THEY ARE OUTRAGED BY
ILLEGAL ALIENS NEAR THEIR ISLAND
VACATION HOMES.
FOR LONG TO BE TWEETING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE VINEYARDS
WHITE COMMUNITY.
I STAND WITH MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
A LITTLE ISLAND EMOJIS IN THE
BIOS.
HILARIOUS, THAT COULD ACTUALLY
HAPPEN.
IN THE END, LIBERALS REALLY DO
STAND WITH MARTHA'S VINEYARD
AGAINST EVERYONE ELSE.
AND HONESTLY ON SOME LEVEL WE
CAN KIND OF UNDERSTAND WHY.
OVER BEING HONEST, WE DON'T WANT
TO SEE MARTHA'S VINEYARD
TRASHED.
WE ARE AMERICANS.
AND MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS A
BEATABLE PLACE, IT IS A SIN TO
DESTROY A BIT AWFUL THINGS,
ALWAYS.
FORTUNATELY, AND THIS REALLY IS
THE POINT, MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS
ONE OF THE DWINDLING NUMBERS OF
PLACES LEFT IN OUR COUNTRY.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS WHAT MOST
OF AMERICA ONCE WAS.
NOT ALL THAT LONG AGO.
A SMALL, SOCIALLY CONCLUSIVE,
ORDERLY, SAFE, WITH TRADITIONAL
HUMAN CENTERED ARCHITECTURE.
BIG STRETCHES OF NATURE.
UNSPOILED BY INDUSTRIAL WIND
FARMS AND DOLLAR STORES.
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD MARTHA'S VINEYARD
DIDN'T BUILD ANY OF THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO DID BUILD IT ARE
LONG GONE.
ALONG WITH THE ATTITUDES AND
VALUES THAT MADE IT POSSIBLE.
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE NOW
JUST CAME FROM NOSTALGIA AND ALL
THAT STUFF REALLY ARE THE
BUILDINGS AND THE BEACHES, BUT
STILL YOU'D HATE TO SEE.
ON THE OTHER HAND WE MIGHT HAVE
NO CHOICE.
NO SANE COUNTRY IT WOULD ALLOW
MILLIONS OF FOREIGN NATIONAL TO
WALK ACROSS ITS BORDERS
ILLEGALLY AND THEN MEAGERLY GIVE
THEM GOVERNMENT BENEFITS IN
EXCHANGE FOR MOCKING OUR RULE OF
LAW.
NO ONE WOULD EVER DO THAT, IT IS
SUICIDE.
OVER TIME IT WILL DESTROY THE
UNITED STATES.
EVERYONE CAN SEE THAT NO MATTER
WHAT THEY SAY.
THE PEOPLE WHO VACATION DON'T
CARE.
YOU'RE MAKING THIS POSSIBLE.
HE SUPPORTED, THEY VOTE FOR IT,
THEY FIND IT.
AND THEY CAN DO ALL OF THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE SO INSULATED FROM
THE EFFECTS OF JOE BIDEN'S
LUNATIC IMMIGRATION POLICIES
THAT NONE OF IT MATTERS TO THEM.
THE COUNTRY COLLAPSES, BIG DEAL
THEY LIVE ON AN ISLAND.
THE REST OF US IT IS A BIG DEAL.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY BUT WE ARE
BORN HERE WE PLAN TO DIE HERE WE
HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO GO AND WE
DON'T WANT TO LIVE I